How did "The Wedding Singer" evolve from
just another slapstick comedy into a
beloved blockbuster hit? Here's what went
into making Adam Sandler's retro rom-com.
According to "Wedding Singer" screenwriter
Tim Herlihy, there wasn't a conscious effort
to make the film drastically different
from "Billy Madison" or "Happy Gilmore."
The formula had been working for both
the fans and the box office receipts,
so there wasn't a need to reinvent it. But as
work got underway on the pair's third film,
it ended up naturally evolving into a more
grounded and more romance-focused film.
Herlihy credits the fact that he had
recently gotten married as part of the
reason why the script began to become more of
a grown-up romantic comedy rather than another
silly romp about a bumbling man-child. He also
says that the change was inspired by Sandler's
terrific chemistry with Drew Barrymore,
and the fact that test audiences didn't
mind scenes where her character was the
focus and Sandler wasn't on screen at all.
The latter was deemed unacceptable by test
audiences of the previous two Sandler films,
forcing those movies to cut almost
any scene that Sandler wasn't in.
Adam Sandler wisely surrounds himself with
fantastic character actors in his films,
and one of the best that he ever worked with
was Alexis Arquette. While Arquette's Boy
George-obsessed "Wedding Singer" bandmate
could have easily been extremely one-note
and only useful for a single punchline, George
Stitzer proved to be an effective and ongoing
presence throughout the film and was responsible
for just as many warm moments as funny ones.
It seems obvious enough that Arquette's
performance came from a place of affection
for the singer, but it isn't always clear how
the person being parodied is going to take the
impression. However, during a concert with his
band Culture Club the day after Arquette passed
away in 2016, George paid tribute to Arquette,
saying she played him, quote, "very hilariously"
and that he enjoyed Arquette's work in the film.
He then dedicated his performance of his classic
song "Do You Really Want To Hurt Me" to Arquette,
as that was the song she got stuck singing over
and over again to an increasingly frustrated
audience in her biggest scene in the film.
"You suuuuuuck!"
If you need a character to
have a real woman's voice,
you often need to get a woman to write her
words. That is exactly what happened when
none other than Carrie Fisher was brought
in to do uncredited script doctor work on
"The Wedding Singer," specifically to tweak
the dialogue of Drew Barrymore's character.
"I don't need a big wedding."
In fact, Fisher had been doing that very
thing for years, and she's worked on a
number of different movies. Her earliest
examples of uncredited dialogue work came
in the original "Star Wars" films. She grew
frustrated when Harrison Ford's rewriting of
his own Han Solo dialogue began to have a
negative impact on Princess Leia's lines,
so she decided to rewrite hers as well. George
Lucas liked her work so much that he asked her
to write an episode of "The Young Indiana
Jones Chronicles" and also help him with
the dialogue in the "Star Wars" prequels. Fisher
eventually became a sought after script doctor,
doing script work on such films as "Last Action
Hero," "Hook," "Scream 3," and "Coyote Ugly."
Adam Sandler movies, at least the ones
that he either co-wrote or were written
specifically for him, have rarely been a
hit with the critics. It's only when he
appears in a movie that he merely acts
in — like "Punch-Drunk Love" or "Uncut
Gems" — that critics manage to appreciate his
work. Considering he has a net worth of almost
half a billion dollars and was eventually
deemed worthy of $20 million-per-movie
paydays that are typically reserved for
blockbuster action stars, it's clear that
the moviegoing public doesn't see eye to eye with
the critics. He's probably just fine with that.
With all that being said, not all
Adam Sandler movies have been met
with unanimous disapproval from critics. In fact,
even "Happy Gilmore" managed to just squeak
by with a "Fresh" rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
But "The Wedding Singer" comes in at a respectable
69%, making it the highest-rated of films he's
penned, and fifth overall of his movies
to date. While a few of the higher-rated
movies have comedic elements, they are
just as equally dramas, and the case can
easily be made that "The Wedding Singer" is the
highest-rated pure comedy of Sandler's career.
"Is it your confidence? Are
you nervous about your penis?"
Adam Sandler movies were basically an
annual event in the '90s. Every fall
meant a new Adam Sandler comedy — until New
Line Cinema messed that up when they decided
that "The Wedding Singer" would work better
if it was released close to Valentine's Day.
So they pushed it from its originally-planned
fall 1997 release into February 1998,
in hopes that couples would see it as part
of a romantic dinner and a movie date.
It's hard to tell how much more business the new
release date actually drove to the movie and how
much of it was just Sandler's huge star power at
that time, but the box office tallies no doubt
made New Line very happy. Still, the side effect
was that 1997 saw zero new Adam Sandler movies,
while 1998 saw two: "The Wedding Singer" in
February, followed by "The Waterboy" in November.
Moviegoers clearly didn't have Sandler fatigue at
that point, as "The Waterboy" was also a huge hit
— much bigger than "The Wedding Singer" in fact,
with more than double its domestic box office.
Combined, Adam Sandler movies brought in roughly
$242 million at the box office that year just
in the U.S.. With only two comedies, that's an
impressive figure no matter how it's distributed.
"Is it true that you're in the
middle of a nervous breakdown?"
"No!"
It's impossible to deny what a wonderful onscreen
couple Adam Sandler and Drew Barrymore make.
Their chemistry is palpable from their very first
scene together in "The Wedding Singer," and it is
very easy to see how quickly they are able to
fall in love despite the obstacles that stand
in their way. Barrymore claims that she could
tell she and Sandler would be great together
even before the two met. She says she approached
Sandler and revealed that she believed them to be
"cinematic soul mates," a claim which she admits
must have sounded crazy to him at the time.
As crazy as it might have sounded, it proved
to be accurate. Not only were the two great
together in "The Wedding Singer," but they
reteamed on "50 First Dates," which was yet
another example of how well they clicked
on-screen. It would also be the first time
that Sandler revisited a female co-lead,
something he typically does only in direct
sequels like "Grown Ups 2." In fact, the duo
couldn't resist making a third movie together,
which they did in 2014's "Blended." That one
might have failed to recapture the magic of
their previous pairings, but it definitely
speaks to how well the two actors get along.
"I think I'm in love with her."
With so many scenes in "The Wedding
Singer" taking place at weddings,
the movie is full of crowds of people that are
difficult to keep track of. Among those crowds
is an actor who was at the time mostly
known only to stand-up comedy nerds,
but would soon be familiar to
mainstream audiences as well.
During Robbie's bitter performance of "Love
Stinks," he goes around and gets various
eclectic members of the crowd involved — from
a woman with sideburns to a man stuffing his
face to an entire table of people he regrettably
refers to as "mutants." Among the group of people
at table nine that Robbie is cruel to is comedian
Brian Posehn in his first film role. He's easy to
miss at first, but once the entire table belts out
"love stinks!" in unison he's much easier to spot.
Prior to "The Wedding Singer," Posehn
previously appeared in "Mr. Show with
Bob and David," and he also landed
cameos in "Friends" and "NewsRadio."
After "The Wedding Singer," he scored
a recurring role on "Just Shoot Me!"
and a steady stream of TV and
movie appearances after that.
Billy Idol's appearance in "The Wedding Singer"
likely was a surprise to audiences at the time,
but it was a pleasant one. Idol
showed up as himself, a rock star
flying first class who would
end up helping Robbie win Julia.
Idol would later admit that the main reason he did
the film was that his son was a huge Sandler fan,
and he reasoned that if he was going to have
to see the movie anyway, he might as well be
in it. He showed up during the pivotal scene where
Julia finally officially picks Robbie over Glen,
and it ended up being good for his career.
The cameo introduced him to a whole new
generation of fans who Idol says continued
to follow him for years after the fact.
"Sir? Is that Billy Idol?"
"I believe it is."
Although Robbie sings a lot in "The Wedding
Singer," both as part of his gig and just
in impromptu performances for Julia,
it isn't technically a musical. But it
became one when screenwriter Tim Herlihy
teamed with Chad Beguelin and Matthew
Sklar to adapt it into a full-fledged
Broadway production. After previews,
it officially opened in February 2006 and
ran until the end of the year on Broadway
before becoming a touring production in 2007 and
beyond. Versions of the "Wedding Singer" musical
have been performed in at least 30 cities in the
U.S., as well as Canada, Europe, and Australia.
While "The Wedding Singer" movie was never
going to rack up any Academy Award nominations,
the musical was much better respected by
the live theater counterpart. The show was
nominated for five Tony Awards: Best Musical,
Best Book of a Musical, Best Original Score,
Best Choreography, and Best Performance of
an Actor In A Leading Role in a Musical.
It didn't end up winning any of those
awards, but it's still impressive that
the "Wedding Singer" musical can proclaim
that it's a five-time Tony Award nominee.
These days, we take for granted
the ability to stream music,
but it wasn't that way in the '90s. In the case
of "The Wedding Singer," buying the soundtrack
was an easy and affordable way to instantly own
a collection of a dozen or so classic '80s hits
all in one place. A lot of people jumped at
that chance, as the soundtrack went double
platinum in the U.S. and also sold very
well in Canada, Australia, and the U.K.
The soundtrack for "The Wedding Singer" was so
successful, in fact, that it was the rare example
of a movie soundtrack later having a "Volume 2."
The second installment included songs from the
movie that weren't among the first batch, like
Adam Sandler's "Grow Old With You." In fact,
both "Wedding Singer" soundtracks are so
well loved that they've even since been
re-released in vinyl format, which is
fitting for a collection of '80s tunes.
As Adam Sandler built up his
resume of lead roles in the '90s,
there was a time when each movie did
better than the last at the box office.
"Billy Madison" grossed $25 million,
"Happy Gilmore" topped that at $39 million,
and then "The Wedding Singer" blew them both
out of the water with an $80 million domestic
box office tally. Needless to say, Sandler
had arrived as a bankable comedy movie lead.
"Sir, one more outburst I will strangle you
with my microphone wire, you understand me?"
But what "The Wedding Singer" also announced
was the arrival of Adam Sandler as a global
superstar. While his previous two films
barely did any business outside of the U.S.,
"The Wedding Singer" added a combined $43 million
in its global release, pushing him over the
$100 million mark worldwide for the first time.
Granted, he had no trouble passing $100 million
just in the U.S. on his next handful or so of
releases, not counting notable early outlier
dud "Little Nicky." But it's still important to
take note of the movie that first got him into the
nine figure club and extended his reach beyond the
States, and that movie was "The Wedding Singer."
Adam Sandler movies reuse a lot of the
same actors, but he's also been generous when it
comes to finding parts for some of his old pals,
including Allen Covert, Peter Dante , and
Jonathan Loughran, giving them roles both in
front of and behind the camera. Loughran
has also served as Sandler's assistant,
while Covert has been a producer on basically
every Happy Madison production to date.
Early in his career, Sandler initially didn't have
the clout for this, but on "The Wedding Singer,"
Sandler could finally pull the strings needed to
not only get Covert a major part as Robbie's best
friend, but he also brought Peter Dante into the
fold with a minor role in the beginning. Covert,
Dante, and Loughran would go on to have
bigger roles in subsequent Sandler movies,
and have even forged careers
outside of Happy Madison as well.